alright guys welcome to this first LG
boiler video series video I've decided
to do this video tutorial because of a
large number of cases and just products
that I'm getting young in number one in
the peel box and my um being sent to me
for me to do reviews and a lot of these
are cases and accessories for the LG
boiler so I just want to go over number
one this is the first video of the LG
Voyager basically overview series so the
first part this video is going to be
hardware so I have the phone right here
and this is obviously a touchscreen
phone on the front and a multimedia
texting device on the inside now I'm
still trying to play a voice to get the
brightness down but until then the only
way I could really show you guys what's
clear is to hold it at an angle
basically our hardware is a send button
at the end button and a clear button in
the middle this is on the front of the
phone and your speaker's here and your
microphone I believe is also your
microphone it's probably down here but I
haven't actually seen the hardware of it
yet right in front of this slide all we
have is a 2.5 not a 3.5 a 2.5 millimeter
headphone jack and a micro SD card slot
now I did do a video on using a micro SD
card so go ahead and check that out if
you haven't already and we'll flip to
the bottom here this is just the report
where we can charge it you just flip
that back and I'm mini USB charger right
there
proprietary USB I can close that up it's
just a little rubber so same thing turn
to the other side and we have on the top
here a hard camera button yeah hold hold
switch basically you pull it back and
forth to hold it and turn the phone from
hold on and off and the volume rocker
here's also serves as a as soon button
when you're holding it as a camera like
this you can zoom in and out using these
two and there's nothing actually on the
top of the phone except for my first
little Nick and so on the back of the
phone you can see here if I pull it up
is the 2.0 megapixel camera if I can get
this to focus at all this is the 2.0
megapixel camera on
for themselves kind of hard to focus
there we go it's a relatively decent
camera it takes 1600 read 1200 there you
see me here take 1600 by 1200 shots so
it's really been hard we're actually on
the inside we obviously have the full
QWERTY keyboard a lot of people like
this actual tactile keyboard that send a
tender on this side the okay and the
whole navigation is on the right hand
side speakerphone button is this one I'm
Carolee at the focus speaker boehner's
here the function button shifter on here
and here so you know it's very basically
out your soft keys are left and right
and yes if you open the phone all the
way you can still use those hard buttons
when you're actually using a camera I'll
show you that right now
if I turn this device back on just with
the camera button on those two zoom
buttons that I showed you before as you
can see there that's in my room if I I'm
just pressing actually I'm in the
highest resolution here so I won't be
able to zoom but if I turn it all the
way down look you can see that very dumb
zooming in and zooming out using this
some sexual zoom hard button on the top
so yeah that's basically a general
hardware early dude this is a little
Chrome on the side a pretty high
resolution screen and again it is a
touch screen on the front and I'll be
doing more reviews of the software and
how it actually works but you can see
the phone the screen itself doesn't take
up the entire the screen itself does not
take up the entire phone so I have
little Verizon Wireless and LG branding
on the sides but overall it's a nice
hardware interface is 50 in your pocket
it's very sturdy and I do like the phone
so again stay tuned for the hardware
reviews stay tuned for the case reviews
and unboxings and I hope you guys liked
this first video so thanks for checking
me out and make sure you subscribe these